Professor Paul Bloom:
I actually want to begin by
going back to Freud and hitting
a couple of loose ends.
There was a point in my lecture
on Wednesday where I skipped
over some parts.
I said, "We don't have time for
this" and I just whipped past
it.
And I couldn't sleep over the
weekend.
I've been tormented.
I shouldn't have skipped that
and I want to hit--Let me tell
you why I skipped it.
The discussion I skipped was
the discussion of why we would
have an unconscious at all.
So, I was talking about the
scientifically respectable ideas
of Freud and I want to talk
about some new ideas about why
there could be an unconscious.
Now, the reason why I skipped
it is I'm not sure this is the
best way to look at the
question.
As we will learn throughout the
course, by far the vast majority
of what our brains do,
the vast majority of what our
minds do, is unconscious and
we're unaware of it.
So the right question to ask
may not be, "Why are some things
unconscious?"
but rather, why is this tiny
subset of mental life--why is
this conscious?
On the other hand,
these claims about the utility
of unconsciousness,
I think, are provocative and
interesting.
So I just wanted to quickly
share them with you.
So, the question is,
from an evolutionary
standpoint, "Why would an
unconscious evolve?"
And an answer that some
psychologists and biologists
have given is deception.
So, most animals do some
deception.
And deception defined broadly
is simply to act or be in some
way that fools others into
believing or thinking or
responding to something that's
false.
There's physical examples of
deception.
When threatened,
chimpanzees--their hair stands
up on end and that makes them
look bigger to fool others to
thinking they're more dangerous
than they are.
There's an angler fish at the
bottom of the ocean that has a
rod sticking up from the top of
its head with a lure to capture
other fish – to fool them in
thinking that this is something
edible and then to themselves be
devoured.
But humans, primates in general
but particularly humans,
are masters of deception.
We use our minds and our
behaviors and our actions
continually to try to trick
people into believing what's not
true.
We try to trick people,
for instance,
into believing that we're
tougher, smarter,
sexier, more reliable,
more trustworthy and so on,
than we really are.
And a large part of social
psychology concerns the way in
which we present ourselves to
other people so as to make the
maximally positive impression
even when that impression isn't
true.
At the same time,
though, we've also evolved very
good lie detection mechanisms.
So not only is there
evolutionary pressure for me to
lie to you, for me to persuade
you for instance,
that if we're going to have
a--if you are threatening me
don't threaten me,
I am not the sort of man you
could screw around with.
But there's evolutionary
pressure for you to look and
say, "No.
You are the sort of man you
could screw around with.
I can tell."
So how do you become a good
liar?
And here's where the
unconscious comes in.
The hypothesis is:
the best lies are lies we tell
ourselves.
You're a better liar,
more generally,
if you believe the lie that
you're telling.
This could be illustrated with
a story about Alfred Hitchcock.
The story goes--He hated
working with child actors but he
often had to.
And the story goes--He was
dealing with a child actor who
simply could not cry.
And, finally frustrated,
Hitchcock went to the actor,
leaned over,
whispered in his ear,
"Your parents have left you and
they're never coming back."
The kid burst into tears.
Hitchcock said,
"Roll ‘em" and filmed the
kid.
And the kid,
if you were to see him,
you'd say, "That's--Boy,
he's--he really looks as if
he's sad" because he was.
If I had a competition where
I'd give $100,000 to the person
who looks the most as if they
are in pain,
it is a very good tactic to
take a pen and jam it into your
groin because you will look
extremely persuasively as if you
are in pain.
If I want to persuade you that
I love you, would never leave
you, you can trust me with
everything, it may be a superb
tactic for me to believe it.
And so, this account of the
evolution of the unconscious is
that certain motivations and
goals,
particularly sinister ones,
are better made to be
unconscious because if a person
doesn't know they have them they
will not give them away.
And this is something I think
we should return to later on
when we talk about social
interaction and social
relationships.
One other thing on Freud--just
a story of the falsification of
Freud.
I was taking my younger child
home from a play date on Sunday
and he asked me out of the blue,
"Why can't you marry your
mother or your father?"
Now, that's actually a
difficult question to ask--to
answer for a child,
but I tried my best to give him
an answer.
And then I said--then I thought
back on the Freud lecture and so
I asked him, "If you could marry
anybody you want,
who would it be?"
imagining he'd make explicit
the Oedipal complex and name his
mother.
Instead, he paused for a moment
and said, "I would marry a
donkey and a big bag of
peanuts."
[laughter]
Both his parents are
psychologists and he hates these
questions and at times he just
screws around with us.
[laughter] Okay.
Last class I started with Freud
and now I want to turn to
Skinner.
And the story of Skinner and
science is somewhat different
from the story of Freud.
Freud developed and championed
the theory of psychoanalysis by
himself.
It is as close as you could
find in science to a solitary
invention.
Obviously, he drew upon all
sorts of sources and
predecessors but psychoanalysis
is identified as Freud's
creation.
Behaviorism is different.
Behaviorism is a school of
thought that was there long
before Skinner,
championed by psychologists
like John Watson,
for instance.
Skinner came a bit late into
this but the reason why we've
heard of Skinner and why Skinner
is so well known is he packaged
these notions.
He expanded upon them;
he publicized them;
he developed them
scientifically and presented
them both to the scientific
community and to the popular
community and sociologically in
the 1960s and 1970s.
In the United States,
behaviorism was incredibly well
known and so was Skinner.
He was the sort of person you
would see on talk shows.
His books were bestsellers.
Now, at the core of behaviorism
are three extremely radical and
interesting views.
The first is a strong emphasis
on learning.
The strong view of behaviorism
is everything you know,
everything you are,
is the result of experience.
There's no real human nature.
Rather, people are infinitely
malleable.
There's a wonderful quote from
John Watson and in this quote
John Watson is paraphrasing a
famous boast by the Jesuits.
The Jesuits used to claim,
"Give me a child until the age
of seven and I'll show you the
man,"
that they would take a child
and turn him into anything they
wanted.
And Watson expanded on this
boast,
Give me a dozen healthy
infants, well-formed and my own
specified world to bring them up
and I'll guarantee to take any
one at random and train them to
become any type of specialist I
might select--doctor,
lawyer, artist,
merchant, chief,
and yes, even beggar-man and
thief, regardless of his
talents,
penchants, tendencies,
abilities, vocations and race
of his ancestors.
Now, you could imagine--You
could see in this a tremendous
appeal to this view because
Watson has an extremely
egalitarian view in a sense.
If there's no human nature,
then there's no sense in which
one group of humans by dint of
their race or their sex could be
better than another group.
And Watson was explicit.
None of those facts about
people will ever make any
difference.
What matters to what you are is
what you learn and how you're
treated.
And so, Watson claimed he could
create anybody in any way simply
by treating them in a certain
fashion.
A second aspect of behaviorism
was anti-mentalism.
And what I mean by this is the
behaviorists were obsessed with
the idea of doing science and
they felt,
largely in reaction to Freud,
that claims about internal
mental states like desires,
wishes, goals,
emotions and so on,
are unscientific.
These invisible,
vague things can never form the
basis of a serious science.
And so, the behaviorist
manifesto would then be to
develop a science without
anything that's unobservable and
instead use notions like
stimulus and response and
reinforcement and punishment and
environment that refer to real
world and tangible events.
Finally, behaviorists believed
there were no interesting
differences across species.
A behaviorist might admit that
a human can do things that a rat
or pigeon couldn't but a
behaviorist might just say,
"Look.
Those are just general
associative powers that differ"
or they may even deny it.
They might say,
"Humans and rats aren't
different at all.
It's just humans tend to live
in a richer environment than
rats."
From that standpoint,
from that theoretical
standpoint, comes a
methodological approach which
is,
if they're all the same then
you could study human learning
by studying nonhuman animals.
And that's a lot of what they
did.
Okay.
I'm going to frame my
introduction--my discussion of
behaviors in terms of the three
main learning principles that
they argue can explain all of
human mental life,
all of human behavior.
And then, I want to turn to
objections to behaviorism but
these three principles are
powerful and very interesting.
The first is habituation.
This is the very simplest form
of learning.
And what this is is technically
described as a decline in the
tendency to respond to stimuli
that are familiar due to
repeated exposure.
"Hey!"
The sudden noise startles but
as it--as you hear it a second
time it startles less.
The third time is just me being
goofy.
It's just--It's--You get used
to things.
And this, of course,
is common enough in everyday
life.
We get used to the ticking of a
clock or to noise of traffic but
it's actually a very important
form of learning because imagine
life without it.
Imagine life where you never
got used to anything,
where suddenly somebody steps
forward and waves their hand and
you'd go,
"Woah," and then they wave
their hand again and you'd go,
"Whoah," and you
keep--[laughter]
And there's the loud ticking of
a clock and you say,
"Hmmm."
And that's not the way animals
or humans work.
You get used to things.
And it's actually critically
important to get used to things
because it's a useful adaptive
mechanism to keep track on new
events and objects.
It's important to notice
something when it's new because
then you have to decide whether
it's going to harm you,
how to deal with it,
to attend to it,
but you can't keep on noticing
it.
And, in fact,
you should stop noticing it
after it's been in the
environment for long enough.
So, this counts as learning
because it happens through
experience.
It's a way to learn through
experience, to change your way
of thinking through experience.
And also, it's useful because
harmful stimuli are noticed but
when something has shown itself
to be part of the environment
you don't notice it anymore.
The existence of habituation is
important for many reasons.
One thing it's important for is
clever developmental
psychologists have used
habituation as a way to study
people,
creatures who can't talk like
nonhuman animals,
and young babies.
And when I talk on Wednesday
about developmental psychology
I'll show different ways in
which psychologists have used
habituation to study the minds
of young babies.
The second sort of learning is
known as classical conditioning.
And what this is in a very
general sense is the learning of
an association between one
stimulus and another stimulus,
where stimulus is a technical
term meaning events in the
environment like a certain smell
or sound or sight.
It was thought up by Pavlov.
This is Pavlov's famous dog and
it's an example of scientific
serendipity.
Pavlov, when he started this
research, had no interest at all
in learning.
He was interested in saliva.
And to get saliva he had to
have dogs.
And he had to attach something
to dogs so that their saliva
would pour out so he could study
saliva.
No idea why he wanted to study
saliva, but he then discovered
something.
What he would do is he'd put
food powder in the dog's mouth
to generate saliva.
But Pavlov observed that when
somebody entered the room who
typically gave him the food
powder,
the dog--the food powder saliva
would start to come out.
And later on if you--right
before or right during you give
the dog some food – you ping a
bell – the bell will cause the
saliva to come forth.
And, in fact,
this is the apparatus that he
used for his research.
He developed the theory of
classical conditioning by making
a distinction between two sorts
of conditioning,
two sorts of stimulus response
relationships.
One is unconditioned.
An unconditioned is when an
unconditioned stimulus gives
rise to an unconditioned
response.
And this is what you start off
with.
So, if somebody pokes you with
a stick and you say,
"Ouch," because it hurts,
the poking and the "ouch" is an
unconditioned stimulus causing
an unconditioned response.
You didn't have to learn that.
When Pavlov put food powder in
the dog's mouth and saliva was
generated, that's an
unconditioned stimulus giving
rise to an unconditioned
response.
But what happens through
learning is that another
association develops – that
between the conditioned stimulus
and the conditioned response.
So when Pavlov,
for instance--Well,
when Pavlov,
for instance,
started before conditioning
there was simply an
unconditioned stimulus,
the food in the mouth,
and an unconditioned response,
saliva.
The bell was nothing.
The bell was a neutral stimulus.
But over and over again,
if you put the bell and the
food together,
pretty soon the bell will
generate saliva.
And now the bell--When--You
start off with the unconditioned
stimulus, unconditioned
response.
When the conditioned stimulus
and the unconditioned stimulus
are brought together over and
over and over again,
pretty soon the conditioned
stimulus gives rise to the
response.
And now it's known as the
conditioned stimulus giving rise
to the conditioned response.
This is discussed in detail in
the textbook but I also--I'm
going to give you--Don't panic
if you don't get it quite now.
I'm going to give you further
and further examples.
So, the idea here is,
repeated pairings of the
unconditioned stimulus and the
conditioned stimulus will give
rise to the response.
And there's a difference
between reinforced trials and
unreinforced trials.
A reinforced trial is when the
conditioned stimulus and the
unconditioned stimulus go
together.
You're--and to put it in a
crude way, you're teaching the
dog that the bell goes with the
food.
An unreinforced trial is when
you get the food without the
bell.
You're not teaching the dog
this.
And, in fact,
once you teach an animal
something, if you stop doing the
teaching the response goes away
and this is known as extinction.
But here's a graph.
If you get--They really count
the number of cubic centimeters
of saliva.
The dog is trained so that when
the bell comes on--Actually,
I misframed it.
I'll try again.
When the bell comes connected
with food, there's a lot of
saliva.
An unreinforced response is
when the bell goes on but
there's no food.
So, it's--Imagine you're the
dog.
So, you get food in your mouth,
"bell, food,
bell, food," and now "bell."
But next you get "bell,
bell, bell."
You give it up.
You stop.
You stop responding to the bell.
A weird thing which is
discussed in the textbook is if
you wait a while and then you
try it again with the bell after
a couple of hours,
the saliva comes back.
This is known as spontaneous
recovery.
So, this all seems a very
technical phenomena related to
animals and the like but it's
easy to see how it generalizes
and how it extends.
One interesting notion is that
of stimulus generalization.
And stimulus generalization is
the topic of one of your
articles in The Norton
Reader,
the one by Watson,
John Watson,
the famous behaviorist,
who reported a bizarre
experiment with a baby known as
Little Albert.
And here's the idea.
Little Albert originally liked
rats.
In fact, I'm going to show you
a movie of Little Albert
originally liking rats.
See.
He's okay.
No problem.
Now, Watson did something
interesting.
As Little Albert was playing
with the rat,
"Oh, I like rats,
oh," Watson went behind the
baby--this is the--it's in the
chapter--and banged the metal
bar right here .
The baby, "Aah," screamed,
started to sob.
Okay.
What's the unconditioned
stimulus?
Somebody.
The loud noise,
the bar, the bang.
What's the unconditioned
response?
Crying, sadness, misery.
And as a result of this,
Little Albert grew afraid of
the rat.
So there--what would be the
conditioned stimulus?
The rat.
What would be the conditioned
response?
Fear.
Excellent.
Moreover, this fear extended to
other things.
So, this is a very weird and
unpersuasive clip.
But the idea is--the clip is to
make the point that the fear
will extend to a rabbit,
a white rabbit.
So, the first part,
Little Albert's fine with the
white rabbit.
The second part is after he's
been conditioned and he's kind
of freaked out with the white
rabbit.
The problem is in the second
part they're throwing the rabbit
at him but now he's okay.
[laughter] Is the mic on?
Oh.
This is fine.
This is one of a long list of
experiments that we can't do
anymore.
So, classical conditioning is
more than a laboratory
phenomena.
The findings of classical
conditioning have been extended
and replicated in all sorts of
animals including crabs,
fish, cockroaches and so on.
And it's been argued to be an
extension of--it's argued to
underlie certain interesting
aspects of human responses.
So, I have some examples here.
One example is fear.
So, the Little Albert idea--The
Little Albert experiment,
provides an illustration for
how phobias could emerge.
Some proportion of people in
this room have phobias.
Imagine you're afraid of dogs.
Well, a possible story for
the--for why you became afraid
of dogs is that one day a dog
came up and he was a neutral
stimulus.
No problem.
And all of a sudden he bit you.
Now the pain of a bite,
being bit, and then the pain
and fear of that is an
unconditioned stimulus,
unconditioned response.
You're just born with that,
"ow."
But the presence of the dog
there is a conditioned stimulus
and so you grew to be afraid of
dogs.
If you believe this,
this also forms the basis for
ways for a theory of how you
could make phobias go away.
How do you make conditioned
stimulus, conditioned response
things go away?
Well, what you do is you
extinguish them.
How do you extinguish them?
Well, you show the thing that
would cause you to have the fear
without the unconditioned
stimulus.
Here's an illustration.
It's a joke.
Sorry.
He's simultaneously confronting
the fear of heights,
snakes, and the dark because
he's trapped in that thing and
the logic is--the logic of--the
logic is not bad.
He's stuck in there.
Those are all the--his
conditioned stimulus.
But nothing bad happens so his
fear goes away.
The problem with this is while
he's stuck in there he has this
screaming, horrific panic attack
and then it makes his fear much
worse.
So, what they do now though,
and we'll talk about this much
later in the course when we talk
about clinical psychology--but
one cure for phobias does draw
upon,
in a more intelligent way,
the behaviorist literature.
So, the claim about a phobia is
that there's a bad association
between, say dog and fear,
or between airplanes or snakes
and some bad response.
So, what they do is what's
called, "systematic
desensitization," which is they
expose you to what causes you
the fear but they relax you at
the same time so you replace the
aversive classical conditioned
fear with something more
positive.
Traditionally,
they used to teach people
relaxation exercises but that
proves too difficult.
So nowadays they just pump you
full of some drug to get you
really happy and so you're
really stoned out of your head,
you're and this isn't so bad.
It's more complicated than that
but the notion is you can use
these associative tools perhaps
to deal with questions about
fear,
phobias and how they go away.
Hunger.
We'll spend some time in this
course discussing why we eat and
when we eat.
And one answer to why we eat
and when we eat is that there's
cues in the environment that are
associated with eating.
And these cues generate hunger.
For those of you who are trying
to quit smoking,
you'll notice that there's
time--or to quit drinking
there's times of the day or
certain activities that really
make you want to smoke or really
make you want to drink.
And from a behaviorist point of
view this is because of the
associative history of these
things.
More speculatively,
classical conditioning has been
argued to be implicated in the
formation of sexual desire,
including fetishes.
So a behaviorist story about
fetishes, for instance,
is it's straightforward
classical conditioning.
Just as your lover's caress
brings you to orgasm,
your eyes happen to fall upon a
shoe.
Through the simple tools of
classical conditioning then,
the shoe becomes a conditioned
stimulus giving rise to the
conditioned response of sexual
pleasure.
This almost certainly is not
the right story but again,
just as in phobias,
some ideas of classical
conditioning may play some role
in determining what we like and
what we don't like sexually.
And in fact,
one treatment for pedophiles
and rapists involved controlled
fantasies during masturbation to
shift the association from
domination and violence,
for instance,
to develop more positive
associations with sexual
pleasure.
So the strong classical
conditioning stories about
fetishes and fears sound silly
and extreme and they probably
are but at the same time
classical conditioning can be
used at least to shape the focus
of our desires and of our
interests.
Final thought actually is--Oh,
yeah.
Okay.
So, what do we think about
classical conditioning?
We talked about what
habituation is for.
What's classical conditioning
for?
Well, the traditional view is
it's not for anything.
It's just association.
So, what happens is the UCS and
the CS, the bell and the food,
go together because they happen
at the same time.
And so classical conditioning
should be the strongest when
these two are simultaneous and
the response to one is the same
as the response to the other.
This is actually no longer the
mainstream view.
The mainstream view is now a
little bit more interesting.
It's that what happens in
classical conditioning is
preparation.
What happens is you become
sensitive to a cue that an event
is about to happen and that
allows you to prepare for the
event.
This makes certain predictions.
It predicts that the best
timing is when the conditioned
stimulus, which is the signal,
comes before the unconditioned
stimulus, which is what you have
to prepare for.
And it says the conditioned
response may be different from
the unconditioned response.
So, move away from food.
Imagine a child who's being
beaten by his father.
And when his father raises his
hand he flinches.
Well, that's classical
conditioning.
What happened in that case is
he has learned that the raising
of a hand is a signal that he is
about to be hit and so he
responds to that signal.
His flinch is not the same
response that one would give if
one's hit.
If you're hit, you don't flinch.
If you're hit,
you might feel pain or bounce
back or something.
Flinching is preparation for
being hit.
And, in general,
the idea of what goes on in
classical conditioning is that
the response is sort of a
preparation.
The conditioned response is a
preparation for the
unconditioned stimulus.
Classical conditioning shows up
all over the place.
As a final exercise,
and I had to think about
it--Has anybody here seen the
movie "Clockwork Orange"?
A lot of you.
It's kind of a shocking movie
and unpleasant and very violent
but at its core one of the main
themes is right out of Intro
Psych.
It's classical conditioning.
And a main character,
who is a violent murderer and
rapist, is brought in by some
psychologists for some therapy.
And the therapy he gets is
classical conditioning.
In particular,
what happens is he is given a
drug that makes him violently
ill, extremely nauseous.
And then his eyes are propped
open and he's shown scenes of
violence.
As a result of this sort of
conditioning,
he then – when he experiences
real world violence – he
responds with nausea and shock;
basically, training him to get
away from these acts of
violence.
In this example--Take a moment.
Don't say it aloud.
Just take a moment.
What's the unconditioned
stimulus?
Okay.
Anybody, what's the
unconditioned stimulus?
Somebody just say it.
The drug.
What's the unconditioned
response?
Nausea.
What's the conditioned stimulus?
Violence.
What's the conditioned response?
Perfect.
The third and final type of
learning is known as operant
conditioning or instrumental
conditioning.
And this is the thing,
this is the theory championed
and developed most extensively
by Skinner.
What this is is learning the
relationships between what you
do and how successful or
unsuccessful they are,
learning what works and what
doesn't.
It's important.
This is very different from
classical conditioning and one
way to see how this is different
is for classical conditioning
you don't do anything.
You could literally be strapped
down and be immobile and these
connections are what you
appreciate and you make
connections in your mind.
Instrumental conditioning is
voluntary.
You choose to do things and by
dint of your choices.
Some choices become more
learned than others.
So, the idea itself was
developed in the nicest form by
Thorndike who explored how
animals learn.
Remember behaviorists were
entirely comfortable studying
animals and drawing
extrapolations to other animals
and to humans.
So, he would put a cat in a
puzzle box.
And the trick to a puzzle box
is there's a simple way to get
out but you have to kind of pull
on something,
some special lever,
to make it pop open.
And Thorndike noted that cats
do not solve this problem
through insight.
They don't sit in the box for a
while and mull it over and then
figure out how to do it.
Instead, what they do is they
bounce all around doing
different things and gradually
get better and better at it.
So, what they do is,
the first time they might
scratch at the bars,
push at the ceiling,
dig at the floor,
howl, etc., etc.
And one of their behaviors is
pressing the lever.
The lever gets them out of the
box, but after more and more
trials they stopped scratching
at the bars, pushing at the
ceiling and so on.
They just pressed the lever.
And if you graph it,
they gradually get better and
better.
They throw out all of these
behaviors randomly.
Some of them get reinforced and
those are the ones that survive
and others don't get reinforced
and those are the ones that go
extinct.
And it might occur to some of
you that this seems to be an
analogy with the Darwinian
theory of natural selection
where there's a random
assortment of random mutations.
And sexual selections give rise
to a host of organisms,
some of which survive and are
fit and others which aren't.
And in fact,
Skinner explicitly made the
analogy from the natural
selection of species to the
natural selection of behavior.
So this could be summarized as
the law of effect,
which is a tendency to perform
– an action's increased if
rewarded, weakened if it's not.
And Skinner extended this more
generally.
So, to illustrate Skinnerian
theory in operant conditioning
I'll give an example of training
a pig.
So here is the idea.
You need to train a pig and you
need to do so through operant
conditioning.
So one of the things you want
to do is--The pig is going to do
some things you like and some
things you don't like.
And so what you want to do,
basically drawing upon the law
of effect, is reinforce the pig
for doing good things.
Suppose you want the pig to
walk forward.
So, you reinforce the pig for
walking forward and you punish
the pig for walking backward.
And if you do that over the
fullness of time,
your reinforcement and
punishment will give rise to a
pig who walks forward.
There's two--One technical
distinction that people love to
put on Intro Psych exams is that
the difference between positive
reinforcement and negative
reinforcement.
Reinforcement is something that
makes the behavior increase.
Negative reinforcement is very
different from punishment.
Negative reinforcement is just
a type of reward.
The difference is in positive
reinforcement you do something;
in negative reinforcement you
take away something aversive.
So, imagine the pig has a heavy
collar and to reward the pig for
walking forward you might remove
the heavy collar.
So, these are the basic
techniques to train an animal.
But it's kind of silly because
suppose you want your pig to
dance.
You don't just want your pig to
walk forward.
You want your pig to dance.
Well, you can't adopt the
policy of "I'm going to wait for
this pig to dance and when it
does I'm going to reinforce it"
because it's going to take you a
very long time.
Similarly, if you're dealing
with immature humans and you
want your child to get you a
beer,
you can't just sit,
wait for the kid to give you a
beer and uncap the bottle and
say,
"Excellent.
Good.
Hugs."
You've got to work your way to
it.
And the act of working your way
to it is known as shaping.
So, here is how to get a pig to
dance.
You wait for the pig to do
something that's halfway close
to dancing, like stumbling,
and you reward it.
Then it does something else
that's even closer to dancing
and you reward it.
And you keep rewarding it as it
gets closer to closer.
Here's how to get your child to
bring you some beer.
You say, "Johnny,
could you go to the kitchen and
get me some beer?"
And he walks to the kitchen and
then he forgets why he's there
and you run out there.
"You're such a good kid.
Congratulations.
Hugs."
And then you get him to--and
then finally you get him to also
open up the refrigerator and get
the beer,
open the door,
get the--and in that way you
can train creatures to do
complicated things.
Skinner had many examples of
this.
Skinner developed,
in World War II,
a pigeon guided missile.
It was never actually used but
it was a great idea.
And people, in fact--The
history of the military in the
United States and other
countries includes a lot of
attempts to get animals like
pigeons or dolphins to do
interesting and deadly things
through various training.
More recreational,
Skinner was fond of teaching
animals to play Ping-Pong.
And again, you don't teach an
animal to play Ping-Pong by
waiting for it to play Ping-Pong
and then rewarding it.
Rather, you reward
approximations to it.
And basically,
there are primary reinforcers.
There are some things pigs
naturally like,
food for instance.
There are some things pigs
actually automatically don't
like, like being hit or shocked.
But in the real world when
dealing with humans,
but even when dealing with
animals,
we don't actually always use
primary reinforcers or negative
reinforcers.
What we often use are things
like--for my dog saying,
"Good dog."
Now, saying "Good dog" is not
something your dog has been
built, pre-wired,
to find pleasurable.
But what happens is you can do
a two-step process.
You can make "Good dog"
positive through classical
conditioning.
You give the dog a treat and
say, "Good dog."
Now the phrase "good dog" will
carry the rewarding quality.
And you could use that
rewarding quality in order to
train it.
And through this way
behaviorists have developed
token economies where they get
nonhuman animals to do
interesting things for seemingly
arbitrary rewards like poker
chips.
And in this way you can
increase the utility and ease of
training.
Finally, in the examples we're
giving, whenever the pig does
something you like you reinforce
it.
But that's not how real life
works.
Real life for both humans and
animals involved cases where the
reinforcement doesn't happen all
the time but actually happens
according to different
schedules.
And so, there is the
distinction between fixed
schedules versus ratios –
variable schedules and ratio
versus interval.
And this is something you could
print out to look at.
I don't need to go over it in
detail.
The difference between ratio is
a reward every certain number of
times somebody does something.
So, if every tenth time your
dog brought you the newspaper
you gave it hugs and treats;
that's ratio.
An interval is over a period of
time.
So, if your dog gives you--if
your dog, I don't know,
dances for an hour straight,
that would be an interval
thing.
And fixed versus variable
speaks to whether you give a
reward on a fixed schedule,
every fifth time,
or variable,
sometimes on the third time,
sometimes on the seventh time,
and so on.
And these are--There are
examples here and there's no
need to go over them.
It's easy enough to think of
examples in real life.
So, for example,
a slot machine is variable
ratio.
It goes off after it's been hit
a certain number of times.
It doesn't matter how long it
takes you for--to do it.
It's the number of times you
pull it down.
But it's variable because it
doesn't always go off on the
thousandth time.
You don't know.
It's unpredictable.
The slot machine is a good
example of a phenomena known as
the partial reinforcement
effect.
And this is kind of neat.
It makes sense when you hear it
but it's the sort of finding
that's been validated over and
over again with animals and
nonhumans.
Here's the idea.
Suppose you want to train
somebody to do something and you
want the training such that
they'll keep on doing it even if
you're not training them
anymore,
which is typically what you
want.
If you want that,
the trick is don't reinforce it
all the time.
Behaviors last longer if
they're reinforced
intermittently and this is known
as "the partial reinforcement
effect."
Thinking of this
psychologically,
it's as if whenever you put
something in a slot machine it
gave you money,
then all of a sudden it
stopped.
You keep on doing it a few
times but then you say,
"Fine.
It doesn't work," but what if
it gave you money one out of
every hundred times?
Now you keep on trying and
because the reinforcement is
intermittent you don't expect it
as much and so your behavior
will persist across often a huge
amount of time.
Here's a good example.
What's the very worst thing to
do when your kid cries to go
into bed with you and you don't
want him to go into bed with
you?
Well, one--The worst thing to
do is for any--Actually,
for any form of discipline with
a kid is to say,
"No, absolutely not.
No, no, no, no."
"Okay."
And then later on the kid's
going to say,
"I want to do it again" and you
say no and the kid keeps asking
because you've put it,
well, put it as in a
psychological way,
not the way the behaviorists
would put it.
The kid knows okay,
he's not going to get it right
away, he's going to keep on
asking.
And so typically,
what you're doing inadvertently
in those situations is you're
exploiting the partial
reinforcement effect.
If I want my kid to do
something, I should say yes one
out of every ten times.
Unfortunately,
that's the evolution of
nagging.
Because you nag,
you nag, you nag,
the person says,
"Fine, okay," and that
reinforces it.
If Skinner kept the focus on
rats and pigeons and dogs,
he would not have the impact
that he did but he argued that
you could extend all of these
notions to humans and to human
behavior.
So for an example,
he argued that the prison
system needs to be reformed
because instead of focusing on
notions of justice and
retribution what we should do is
focus instead on questions of
reinforcing good behaviors and
punishing bad ones.
He argued for the notions of
operant conditioning to be
extended to everyday life and
argued that people's lives would
become fuller and more
satisfying if they were
controlled in a properly
behaviorist way.
Any questions about behaviorism?
What are your questions about
behaviorism?
[laughter] Yes.
Student:
[inaudible]--wouldn't there be
extinction after a while?
[inaudible]
Professor Paul Bloom:
Good question.
The discussion was over using
things like poker chips for
reinforcement and the point is
exactly right.
Since the connection with the
poker chips is established
through classical conditioning,
sooner or later by that logic
the poker chips would lose their
power to serve as reinforcers.
You'd have to sort of start it
up again, retrain again.
If you have a dog and you say
"Good dog" to reward the dog,
by your logic,
which is right,
at some point you might as well
give the dog a treat along with
the "Good dog."
Otherwise, "Good dog" is not
going to cut it anymore.
Yes.
Student:
[inaudible]
Professor Paul Bloom:
As far as I know,
Skinner and Skinnerian
psychologists were never
directly involved in the
creation of prisons.
On the other hand,
the psychological theory of
behaviorism has had a huge
impact and I think a lot of
people's ways of thinking about
criminal justice and criminal
law has been shaped by
behaviorist principles.
So for instance,
institutions like mental
institutions and some prisons
have installed token economies
where there's rewards for good
behavior,
often poker chips of a sort.
And then you could cash them in
for other things.
And, to some extent,
these have been shaped by an
adherence to behaviorist
principles.
Okay.
So, here are the three general
positions of behaviorism.
(1) That there is no innate
knowledge.
All you need is learning.
(2) That you could explain
human psychology without mental
notions like desires and goals.
(3) And that these mechanisms
apply across all domains and
across all species.
I think it's fair to say that
right now just about everybody
agrees all of these three claims
are mistaken.
First, we know that it's not
true that everything is learned.
There is considerable evidence
for different forms of innate
knowledge and innate desires and
we'll look--and we'll talk about
it in detail when we look at
case studies like language
learning,
the development of sexual
preference, the developing
understanding of material
objects.
There's a lot of debate over
how much is innate and what the
character of the built-in mental
systems are but there's nobody
who doubts nowadays that a
considerable amount for humans
and other animals is built-in.
Is it true that talking about
mental states is unscientific?
Nobody believes this anymore
either.
Science, particularly more
advanced sciences like physics
or chemistry,
are all about unobservables.
They're all about things you
can't see.
And it makes sense to explain
complex and intelligent behavior
in terms of internal mechanisms
and internal representations.
Once again, the computer
revolution has served as an
illustrative case study.
If you have a computer that
plays chess and you want to
explain how the computer plays
chess,
it's impossible to do so
without talking about the
programs and mechanisms inside
the computer.
Is it true that animals need
reinforcement and punishment to
learn?
No, and there's several
demonstrations at the time of
Skinner suggesting that they
don't.
This is from a classic study by
Tolman where rats were taught to
run a maze.
And what they found was the
rats did fine.
They learn to run a maze faster
and faster when they're
regularly rewarded but they also
learn to run a maze faster and
faster if they are not rewarded
at all.
So the reward helps,
but the reward is in no sense
necessary.
And here's a more sophisticated
illustration of the same point.
Professor Paul Bloom:
And this is the sort of
finding, an old finding from
before most of you were born,
that was a huge embarrassment
for the Skinnerian theory,
as it suggests that rats in
fact had mental maps,
an internal mechanism that they
used to understand the world –
entirely contrary to the
behaviorist idea everything
could be explained in terms of
reinforcement and punishment.
Finally, is it true that
there's no animal-specific
constraints for learning?
And again, the answer seems to
be "no."
Animals, for instance,
have natural responses.
So, you could train a pigeon to
peck for food but that's because
pecking for food is a very
natural response.
It's very difficult to train it
to peck to escape a situation.
You can train it to flap its
wings to escape a situation but
it's very difficult to get it to
flap its wings for food.
And the idea is they have sort
of natural responses that these
learning situations might
exploit and might channel,
but essentially,
they do have certain natural
ways of acting towards the
world.
We know that not all stimuli
and responses are created equal.
So, the Gray textbook has a
very nice discussion of the
Garcia effect.
And the Garcia effect goes like
this.
Does anybody here have any food
aversions?
I don't mean foods you don't
like.
I mean foods that really make
you sick.
Often food aversions in humans
and other animals can be formed
through a form of association.
What happens is suppose you
have the flu and you get very
nauseous and then at the same
point you eat some sashimi for
the first time.
The connection between being
nauseous and eating a new food
is very potent.
And even if you know
intellectually full well that
the sashimi isn't why you became
nauseous, still you'll develop
an aversion to this new food.
When I was younger – when I
was a teenager – I drank this
Greek liqueur,
ouzo, with beer.
I didn't have the flu at the
time but I became violently ill.
And as a result I cannot abide
the smell of that Greek liqueur.
Now, thank God it didn't
develop into an aversion to beer
but-- [laughter]
Small miracles.
But the smell is very
distinctive and for me--was new
to me.
And so, through the Garcia
effect I developed a strong
aversion.
What's interesting though is
the aversion is special so if
you take an animal and you give
it a new food and then you give
it a drug to make it nauseous it
will avoid that food.
But if you take an animal and
you give it a new food and then
you shock it very painfully it
won't avoid the new food.
And the idea is that a
connection between what
something tastes and getting
sick is natural.
We are hard wired to say, "Look.
If I'm going to eat a new food
and I'm going to get nauseous,
I'm going to avoid that food."
The Garcia effect is that this
is special to taste and nausea.
It doesn't extend more
generally.
Finally, I talked about phobias
and I'll return to phobias later
on in this course.
But the claim that people have
formed their phobias through
classical conditioning is almost
always wrong.
Instead, it turns out that
there are certain phobias that
we're specially evolved to have.
So, both humans and
chimpanzees, for instance,
are particularly prone to
develop fears of snakes.
And when we talk about the
emotions later on in the course
we'll talk about this in more
detail.
But what seems likely is the
sort of phobias you're likely to
have does not have much to do
with your personal history but
rather it has a lot to do with
your evolutionary history.
Finally, the other reading
you're going to do for this
part--section of the course is
Chomsky's classic article,
his "Review of Verbal
Behavior."
Chomsky is one of the most
prominent intellectuals alive.
He's still a professor at MIT,
still publishes on language and
thought, among other matters.
And the excerpt you're going to
read is from his "Review of
Verbal Behavior."
And this is one of the most
influential intellectual
documents ever written in
psychology because it took the
entire discipline of behaviorism
and,
more than everything else,
more than any other event,
could be said to have destroyed
it or ended it as a dominant
intellectual endeavor.
And Chomsky's argument is
complicated and interesting,
but the main sort of argument
he had to make is--goes like
this.
When it comes to humans,
the notions of reward and
punishment and so on that
Skinner tried to extend to
humans are so vague it's not
science anymore.
And remember the discussion we
had with regard to Freud.
What Skinner--What Chomsky is
raising here is the concern of
unfalsifiablity.
So, here's the sort of example
he would discuss.
Skinner, in his book Verbal
Behavior,
talks about the question of why
do we do things like talk to
ourselves,
imitate sounds,
create art, give bad news to an
enemy, fantasize about pleasant
situations?
And Skinner says that they all
involve reinforcement;
those are all reinforced
behaviors.
But Skinner doesn't literally
mean that when we talk to
ourselves somebody gives us food
pellets.
He doesn't literally mean even
that when we talk to ourselves
somebody pats us on the head and
says, "Good man.
Perfect.
I'm very proud."
What he means,
for instance,
in this case is well,
talking to yourself is
self-reinforcing or giving bad
news to an enemy is reinforcing
because it makes your enemy feel
bad.
Well, Chomsky says the problem
is not that that's wrong.
That's all true.
It's just so vague as to be
useless.
Skinner isn't saying anything
more.
To say giving bad news to an
enemy is reinforcing because it
makes the enemy feel bad doesn't
say anything different from
giving bad news to an enemy
feels good because we like to
give bad news to an enemy.
It's just putting it in more
scientific terms.
More generally,
Chomsky suggests that the law
of effect when applied to humans
is either trivially true,
trivially or uninterestingly
true, or scientifically robust
and obviously false.
So, if you want to expand the
notion of reward or
reinforcement to anything,
then it's true.
So why did you come--those of
you who are not freshmen--Oh,
you--Why did you come?
All of you, why did you come to
Yale for a second semester?
"Well, I repeated my action
because the first semester was
rewarding."
Okay.
What do you mean by that?
Well, you don't literally mean
that somebody rewarded you,
gave you pellets and stuff.
What you mean is you chose to
come there for the second
semester.
And there's nothing wrong with
saying that but we shouldn't
confuse it with science.
And more generally,
the problem is you can talk
about what other people do in
terms of reinforcement and
punishment and operant
conditioning and classical
conditioning.
But in order to do so,
you have to use terms like
"punishment" and "reward" and
"reinforcement" in such a vague
way that in the end you're not
saying anything scientific.
So, behaviorism as a dominant
intellectual field has faded,
but it still leaves behind an
important legacy and it still
stands as one of the major
contributions of twentieth
century psychology.
For one thing,
it has given us a richer
understanding of certain
learning mechanisms,
particularly with regard to
nonhumans.
Mechanisms like habituation,
classical conditioning and
operant conditioning are real;
they can be scientifically
studied;
and they play an important role
in the lives of animals and
probably an important role in
human lives as well.
They just don't explain
everything.
Finally, and this is something
I'm going to return to on
Wednesday actually,
behaviorists have provided
powerful techniques for training
particularly for nonverbal
creatures so this extends to
animal trainers.
But it also extends to people
who want to teach young children
and babies and also want to help
populations like the severely
autistic or the severely
retarded.
Many of these behaviorist
techniques have proven to be
quite useful.
And in that regard,
as well as in other regards,
it stands as an important
contribution.